the clownfish has been a star in cinemas
around the world on the Andaman Islands
it's one of many denizens of the deep
and some are out of their element
because these divers are Forest Service
officers they're exploring the coastal
waters to experience an ecosystem they
never see at home some are diving for
the first time Shashi Kumar is one of
them the glyph expedia he's come here
from Gujarat a state nearly 3,000
kilometers away in western India on the
andamans Shashi Kumar and his colleagues
want to find out how to live in an
ecosystem without destroying it the
archipelago was chosen consciously
because its biodiversity is especially
great you can see coastal beaches
mangoes and forests little forest which
you can't find it anywhere only Island
you can find a literal for very rich
evergreen forest after that man gross
sasol tolerantly after the beaches then
see in Marin life you can find lot of
corals fishes in animal that impresses
the ten officers who've traveled here
from various Indian coastal regions
they'll be passing on what they've
learned to their colleagues at home
where pressure is increasing more
economic growth pollution and people
forty percent of India's population
lives near the sea if you look at the
Indian coastline we have very small area
which is protected as as a under under
wildlife protection act or for
conservation now there is in the recent
past there is an increased attention to
bring more and
on the area under protection the German
agency for international cooperation GI
Z is co-sponsoring the training it's
part of a larger program aimed at saving
twenty percent of India's more than
7,000 kilometers of coast from
exploitation and destruction coasts need
a different kind of attention than
forests do pedestal area there is no
much resource utilization from the
public it was actually legally protected
area but in the most coastal area not
like that the fishermen communities are
living there they go for years they are
doing a fishing and all those things
suddenly we cannot tell them that you
shouldn't do fishing there and that's
just the problem 3,000 kilometers away
in Gujarat a special economic zone
attracts many businesses the bharuch
district is one of three regions for
which Shashi Kumar is responsible he's
visiting a village two kilometers from
the coast 500 people live here fishermen
and farmers industrial pollution and the
requirements nets with a larger mesh
size are making their lives difficult
it's hard to convince them to use
resources more sparingly so that's
c-band up a little too much we used to
catch 15 kilos of fish a day but now
it's only five or two thank you and
sometimes we don't catch anything at all
nikhil una mala possible
the Forest Service officials know that
people are dependent on what the land
and sea provide for them despite that
they've set up a nature reserve years
ago the Forest Service planted mangrove
trees next to a disused port the area is
a good 20 square kilometers in size
protecting it is a difficult task land
value is very high in this area that it
so there is a possibility of
encouragement by industries by locals by
fishermen by salt makers so to avoid
this and to protect our forestry out to
regularly do patrolling the plants grow
slowly it takes years before they
produce their own seeds now they provide
protection against flooding and the
habitat for fish and crabs and step by
step local residents are beginning to
see those advantages it's planned to
involve the villagers more closely in
the project having them plant and patrol
the mangroves back to the Andamans on
munda pehar beach in the southeast the
beach is a rare example of gentle
ecotourism in India the huts and signs
are made of local wood and the beach is
a paradise for birdwatchers
there are 80 species of birds are
endemic to to say these are young in
Pigeon I think yeah and I'm on clean pjs
80 times m1 creek is the owner endemic
boats actually Shashi Kumar can also
imagine more eco tourism for his home
districts in Gujarat but he's also
learned here that making plans without
involving those affected by them as has
often been done in India doesn't work
stockholders participation locals should
be involved in that involved as a guide
so if there will be models again there
is a less catching our future so that
will be also managed and the direct
impact on the coastal will be reduced it
would be an opportunity to preserve
biodiversity in many of India's coastal
regions not just on the andamans